Speaker 1: I want to talk about a ridiculous
performance by Pennsylvania Republican Senate
candidate Mehmet Oz, and this is the guy many
know it as Dr. Oz. We are doing everything we
can to just refer to him as Mehmet Oz. Because
saying Dr. Oz, almost, it's like it's useful to
him in some way. Oz is running in Pennsylvania.
As I mentioned, the leading Democratic primary
opponent is a guy named John Fetterman, who we're
going to try to get on the show. Very interesting
candidate. And Mehmet Oz apparently wanted to make
the point that groceries are expensive. This is
part of the inflation story that Republicans
have been telling, but Republicans don't want
to tell the story in good faith. There's been
inflation. Gas prices are high, but it's not
Joe Biden's fault. This is happening globally,
but Republicans want to tell the story that it
is Joe Biden's fault. So what Mehmet Oz did is
make a very performative trip to a local grocery
store. And his point at the grocery store is,
look how expensive it is to buy some vegetables.
This is actually an opportunity for Mehmet Oz
to do something useful at the grocery store,
but he doesn't, and I'm going to explain that in
a second. Let's first take a look at the video
Speaker 2: of grocery shopping and awareness.
And my wife wants some vegetables for crudity,
right? So here's a broccoli that's two bucks,
not a ton of broccoli there. Some asparagus
that's four dollars carrots. That's four more
doctors, $10 of vegetables there. And then we
need some guacamole. That's $4 more. And she
loves salsa. Yeah, salsa there. Six dollars must
be a shortage of salsa. Guys, let's take. And
this doesn't include the tequila. I mean, it's
outrageous. And we got Joe Biden the thankless.
Speaker 1: OK. So he he makes a show. By the way,
do we believe he's really there shopping?
I don't. He makes a show of picking up a $2
piece of broccoli and a $4 asparagus and a $4.
It's an enormous bag of carrots for Ford. I think
it's a five pound bag. $4. Guacamole. $6 salsa. So
it's $20 for his crudity. Ingredients. So, first
of all, salsa for crudity. No, that's the first
red flag here. That makes absolutely no sense.
Why are you getting salsa for crudity? But that's
a culinary critique, but it exposes that this is
probably all B.S.. But secondly, it's obviously
super staged to make a political point. He's
not out really shopping for crew to take to make
for his guests. It's absurd. It's like when Mitt
Romney went out to shop and all he had in his cart
was just boxes and boxes of yogurt. And I think,
like seltzer, it was really weird. It wasn't
believable. It was during his presidential
campaign. But this is really a missed opportunity.
Instead of complaining about prices and buying
things that don't even make sense for the
dish you claim to be making as a doctor,
and here's where it is relevant that he's a
medical doctor, he should be explaining to people
how to more economically buy vegetables, which
most Americans aren't getting enough of buying
too many processed foods. Now he's a doctor who's
promoted quack cures on his show called Cures for
Colds that are completely unproven, all sorts of
weird supplements and different things. And then
when he actually has an opportunity to
talk people in a real way about nutrition,
he talks about inflation and tries to blame Joe
Biden. He could have gone and said, Hey, you know
what? Instead of processed foods, here's how you
can get real foods cheaply and make them last.
This would be value if any member of a member of
Congress Congress did this Republican or Democrat,
I would applaud them. This is a big problem in the
United States. People don't know what's healthy.
They don't understand how to economically have
healthier foods. Food products highly processed
are promoted to them. He could go in and go
see this monstrous five pound bag of carrots.
It's four bucks, and that's a good deal. Cut up
some of the carrots. Get hummus for three bucks.
That's a great snack. Take some carrots
and grate them onto your salads to get
more. Whatever. I don't remember, I'm not a
doctor. Is it vitamin A? Whatever carrots have
beta carotene? Take some carrots. Put a little
avocado or olive oil or even canola oil on them
salt and pepper. Roast them. Now you've got great
sides for your lunches instead of potato chips
for the entire week. That's a great
use of a five pound bag of carrots.
Instead, it's a confused guy claiming to be
making crudity with salsa. Hey, let me tell
you about vegetables that are the best value in
the grocery store. We should all be doing more to
eat healthy. Get yourself sweet potatoes. Get the
bulk bag. Roast them alongside your carrots. Keep
them as a side dish for breakfast. Get some eggs.
Toss some cubed up. Already cooked sweet potato.
Fry an egg and then have a handful of blueberries
or whatever the case may be. These are ideas
to buy in larger quantities, don't have food
waste and eat healthier than a highly processed
whatever it is. You know, the granola
bars or whatever it is you're having for,
you know, sugary cereal, whatever. It's
really a wasted opportunity for a doctor
to really provide something of value and show
that he's the type of voice we should be saying.
We need more of that in the Senate. We need. This
is exactly what we need more of in the Senate.
He does something cheap. It adds nothing to the
conversation other than playing the same political
games. That's Mehmet Oz running in Pennsylvania.
Let me know your thoughts. Find me on Twitter
at de Packman. We'll take a quick break.
What a Friday program we have for you today.